from a 240
000 pound travel bill for harry and
megan's tour to africa
to the 210 000 pounds it cost to fly
prince charles to oman
after the sultan's death almost 16 000
pounds for prince andrew to fly
privately to northern ireland for one of
his golf patronages
and princess anne taking a sixteen
thousand pound charter flight to rome
to watch scotland play rugby as their
patron all of them trips that stand out
in the latest royal finances with some
you could argue
more justifiable than others
last year the monarchy and their work
cost the taxpayers 69.4 million pounds
every penny spent on official duties and
building repairs we're told
heavily scrutinized but now they're
going to have to pull the purse strings
even tighter
with covert 19 set to hit the palace
budgets
the royal family is all about image you
know the queen thinks he said we have to
be seen to be believed
and so you know public gestures are
important
and so in these times when you know
everyone is being hit by
by covet you know people are losing
their jobs they're having their
their salaries cut so it's going to look
very bad
if the palace says oh we have a hole in
our finances
and goes to the government cap in hand
and saying oh please give us more
the pandemic stopping the usual visitors
to places like buckingham palace
and windsor castle will mean a 15
million pound shortfall over the next
three years
while the budget for the ongoing repairs
to buckingham palace
is likely to take a 20 million pound hit
the spend on this property is still
attracting attention
we've already been told that harry and
megan have paid off the 2.4 million
pound bill for refurbishing frogmore
cottage
now it's been confirmed they've also
paid an undisclosed sum for rent
but that will appear in next year's
accounts well i suppose there's one way
to train
right from the top the remaining working
royals have adapted in ways we never
expected because of coronavirus
they say they won't be asking for extra
funding but like the rest of the country
will adjust
to the unprecedented impact on their
finances and the way that they work
rihanna mills sky news